primeras impresiones de este discurso a
grandes rasgos porque más adelante vamos
a profundizar sobre cada uno de estos
temas que mencionó
sí No mira la excelente excelente Mira
el presidente habló sobre la historia y
la importancia de nuestra
democracia que es bipartidista hay
éxitos para este congreso si trabajamos
juntos hemos visto que la inversión en
el trabajador a través de las propuestas
que se avanzaron los primeros los años
de la presencia yo bailen han tenido
éxito tenemos una cifra de desempleo
histórico después de 50 años el número
de de individuos que ahora están sin
trabajo está un número más bajo en 50
años especialmente para la comunidad
latina Así que vemos que hay éxito Si
vemos la forma de trabajar juntos en vez
de enfocarnos en dividirnos el
presidente el liderazgo demócrata ha
buscado la manera de avanzar una agenda
que ayuda al estadounidense solo si el
partido republicano se acerca a la mesa
para trabajar juntos hemos visto al
éxito no solo con la economía pero
trabajando con el nivel de inflación y
el presidente
claramente ha puesto una agenda que está
en las manos de los republicanos si
quieren trabajar juntos y es el trabajo
por delante y hay posibilidades de
hacerlo si los republicanos dejan del
extremismo que divide el país